it's always great with the man who along
with michael holly brings you brother
from another every single day at three
eastern time after we are done with this
space on nbc sports on peacock michael
smith back on the show how are you
michael
every single day when we don't take
vacation although i'm not going to
hawaii so well i'm going with my poker
buddies i'm going my poker buddies yeah
that makes a difference i might lose my
shirt there um so it's all good it'll be
fine you going without the family that's
correct susie's sitting in my wife my
she is sitting in his chair she and
marshall faulk are doing all three hours
of the rich eyes and show tomorrow
charles barkley calling in yeah
no that's dope so you can't get wally
pip because the income will still be
coming in if she takes the gig so you're
good there i i that's true
hey look the guy pointing to his temple
that's that's good thinking right there
though
you know it's called next level
michael smith next level uh it's dope
that you get to go see i got to work on
that because i i wonder i need you to
take me aside this conversation because
was that the incentive like babe if you
let me go with the fellas you could hold
down the show and grow your brand
because as we both know rich
when you go on vacation with the family
that's a trip that's not a vacation
that's correct you're taking a vacation
so i need to get i need some pointers as
a fellow father and husband on how to
get this i've never been on a vacation
before by myself nope well uh let's talk
offline on that i'm more than happy to
do that um but just know over the next
couple days i'm i'm out of office and
what island are you going to
our islands
uh i'm going to the big island sir the
big one okay i'm going to oahu all right
uh yeah i've been there so good for you
that's not what you call to talk talking
about though what's up man how you doing
i was super bored i got you out there i
did not run into you like i hope that
was it's great it's great it's all right
i just looked at your instagram account
and saw that you scrubbed all photos of
me off it so um photos all photo all
rich eisen photos off of michael smith's
instagram page um what do you make of
that story the calamari what do you
think is going on
michael yeah you know
it seems like there's a difference in
opinion
um usually the default usually the the
the obvious and the easy
explanation is the right one in these
instances there's a different
disagreement on money he's coming up on
extension time
um and he did not they said you're only
as funky as your last cut uh and he
stunk against the rams as we know and so
um
i'm guessing i'm assuming and i think
it's a safe assumption that there is a
difference uh in
value how the cardinals see him and how
he sees himself but then when all the
dirty laundry starts getting air
see that's how that's how i wonder like
how do you come back from that like does
a contract just make up for that like if
there's enough unhappiness on kyla
murray's part to scrub his social media
accounts of all things cardinals if
there's enough unhappiness on the
cardinals part to put out that he isn't
you know the best thing since sliced
bread himself like how do you come back
and move on for the next 10 years it
just kind of feels like this is the
beginning of the end and it's a matter
of of when not if this relationship ends
one way or the other well i was just
saying this is that if if you think
someone is immature and um and
that person has already scrubbed his
instagram account which one would say
does lack a sense of maturity right yeah
that's very teenager correct and so
if you're dealing with somebody like
that how do you think he's gonna handle
uh
the whisper of he's immature to chris
mortensen how do you think that how do
you think that one's gonna land so i
don't i don't know how you do come back
from that yes a contract will no
question
uh make it better and he can still win
championships for that team but he will
be on a mo hunt forever
in that building that is for sure and
from the cardinals perspective again i i
like calamari i think he's an exciting
player he you know seems like a good kid
i don't know personally and i certainly
don't know the inner workings of the
cardinals as an organization and where
that would have come from or or who
would have been if somebody is inclined
to commit to him why they would have put
that out there the mo to mort but you
know the old saying money doesn't change
you it just makes you more of who you
already are so if they have reservations
about who he is from a character and
leadership standpoint how do you
you know comfortably invest the amount
of money that he's going to be looking
for um it feels
like it's on his way to being you know a
baker mayfield cleveland thing where
it's like hey we gotta see more before
we decide to commit
and
the more you don't
uh going back to relationships you know
we've all been there like hey what are
we you know what are we doing here we
are we are are we gonna you know take
the next step and you're like nah i just
want to chill i just want to kick it i
just want to i'm not ready yet well if
the cardinals aren't ready to commit
fully to colin murray when will they
ever be and by that time will the
relationship be too far gone when he's
like no i remember those whispers to
mort back in the day don't think i
forgot it could be and and then you know
but but
you can't blame the cardinals for saying
to him we don't want to pay you now
because our plan was to pay you
next year
and if we pay you now
we have an issue keeping this guy that
guy that guy that guy we've got to keep
all of this stuff our plan is to pay you
don't worry
be happy right
and
and right
um and and then he
doesn't like that
it's kind of like this is the business
that he's chosen yeah and and
i don't i can understand he would say
well what about josh allen look at the
money that that he made what about the
fact that wentz and goff
got paid and and so
um
that's the conundrum because the
cardinals you're like what they eat
don't make us crap you know um
i guess
it it is
it is what it is if you're calling
murray and i would never begrudge a
player if i want to get his bread if
you're calling murray you feel like
you've done enough you accomplished
enough you were the number one overall
pick let's not forget and i mean it you
know it looks better and better in
hindsight given that we haven't heard
much of anything from josh rosen you
know they went and took him number one
overall when they'd already taken a
quarterback top ten that's how much they
would love with him on the front end uh
they've steadily improved even though
they've collapsed in the second half of
regular seasons nonetheless they
suddenly improved the last couple of
years made the playoffs so if you're him
you're like yo what are we waiting on
but if i i side with the cardinals here
because he was awful
in the playoffs and then they lost the
rams he was awful so if i'm the
cardinals
i would like to see more before
believing that what you're asking for or
what you're looking for or what the
market says
you should be or you're entitled to
think you should be paid
i'm i need to see more before i cut that
check so that's why you have this
face-off and that's why he's you know
scrubbing his instagram and all the
dirty laundry is being added i just
don't know how you put this proverbial
toothpaste back in the tube i guess with
uh nine figures
you know like that's that maybe is the
way to do it michael smith a brother
from another right here on the rich
eisen show on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line what's your take on the
simmons for hardened trade i know the
others are involved those are the
headliners so yeah what's your take on
that well uh basketball wise
i think
sixers
the conventional wisdom is that if you
get the best player you win the trade
they got the best player even if you're
inclined to believe that james harden is
not the player that he once was
maybe the last time he and darryl
murdered together we're together he's
not the same player
but he's still the best player in this
trade however
um
i do think that simmons
when he plays
will be the better fit now what's the
trick part about this whole thing is
usually when teams blow it up it's
either because guys are past their prime
or it's because you know a guy this
money involved there's some
you know typical reason why
uh
an experiment didn't work this one
didn't work for reasons that had nothing
to do with basketball they never played
together the nets i'm talking about and
when they did play together they were
wonderful this was a personality
conflict and james harden just getting
restless so that's the most fascinating
aspect of it this is this is unlike any
kind of star swap we've seen and the
same thing goes for philadelphia they
would just sick of ben simmons act now
having said that on going back to
basketball i think simmons is the better
fit
with
the nets and what they already have and
what they need
then
harden is with the sixers
um even though they weren't getting
anything from simmons to begin with so
while the
uh the sixers got the better player i
would be inclined to think again once he
plays and assuming he's okay that the
nets got the better of the trade but the
broader aspect of it is on hardened side
legacy and only to get into that i'm
just happy to see and hear from ben
simmons
and not that he needs my approval but i
like many others reduced his discontent
to the comments that were made after the
hawk series
um
and other motivations such as ego and
wanting to have his own team and not
want to get along with embiid and this
that any other if he has some personal
issues that preceded his playoff
meltdown and that further complicated it
i just hope he's getting to a place
where he can be happy and be the player
that he's gifted enough to be so i'm
happy for him i'm happy he's got a fresh
start and even though he's in the new
york market uh i would think there's
less pressure on him
um at least to begin with we'll see how
teams are able to exploit his lack of
shooting in the playoffs what do you
make of the concept of his mental health
um being the reason why he couldn't play
for philadelphia and now he's with
brooklyn and he seems to be
um
struggling less with that
michael
you talking about in terms of skepticism
as to whether or not it really just came
down that he didn't want to be in philly
and it's not really mental health and
you know is he using mental health as a
cover you mean that
um let me just put a fine point on it
that yeah that is the conversation being
had in philadelphia and writ large
this could be possible and it is very
touchy subject it could be not it's one
of the touchiest
subjects uh it's one that we you know
take very seriously sure um and so um
what do you think i think you should be
consistent and i know that's what i want
to be
um
it would be a disservice
and it would be unfair and that was the
skepticism to begin with
that you know this is a guy really
throwing a tantrum and using something
very serious
as a shield from further criticism when
he's just not
you know tough enough to handle
what
thousands of players have handled before
him and were handled after him which is
criticism for his own shortcomings but
i'm i'll i'll say this from personal
experience
um
you can't heal where you got sick
and whatever he was dealing with
uh off the court
i can't do anything other than take his
word that there was something else going
on i don't think it's for me or us for
that matter
to dismiss
his claims that he had some stuff going
on in his life
independent of the playoffs and
independent of his relationship with the
sixers and those things only exacerbated
or compounded whatever was going on so
yes is it convenient that he's on the
road to playing again now that he's
gotten what he's wanted it's no
different than our children you know
they throw a tantrum then you give them
what they want they act as sweet as pie
it's like well wait a second you know
what i mean like that's that's not the
way you go about doing things but if he
says that there were issues that he
doesn't want to get into i think if
we're going to be consistent when it
comes to evolving and maturing ourselves
as a society as an industry as
individuals when it comes to discussing
the broad tent that is mental health
then let's be consistent you know let's
not let let's not because we already
have a preconceived notion or we only
already have an opinion about what we
think it is or what we think it should
be let's not let that cloud our judgment
let's not even judge at all i think it's
not a hot tape but i think it's the
right way to go about it if somebody
says i had issues that i don't wanna i
don't really wanna get into that had
nothing to do with the trade
i'm gonna believe him the same way i'm
gonna believe james harden that
philadelphia was his first choice even
though he probably says that's all the
teams at this point so
you know um yeah i i think the best way
to do it is the way we've always been
doing it which is let's be better than
we've been traditionally and
historically when it comes to dismissing
out of hand
somebody's struggling uh with personal
issues i mean they have they have lives
outside of basketball we see the
basketball we see him turning down shots
we see him turning down dunks we see him
demanding a trade and sitting out of
season and and losing a bunch of money
i'll tell you what
i respect the fact that my guy was so
committed to not playing for that
organization again that he forfeited a
big chunk of change
so i would think something must have
really been wrong for him to give up the
millions of dollars that he did michael
smith here on the rich eisen show well
you mentioned how ben simmons turns down
shots he's not the only guy on the nets
who does
so what do you think thank you what do
you think this means
for the nets and sixers in the short
term and long run give it what do you
got for me well they got him under
contract so if
new york and you're more familiar with
that market in the politics of that
market than i am if new york ends up
easing its vaccine mandate
and kyrie irving is able to play
full-time well i got another one for you
i got no i got another joke for you uh i
don't know why everybody was tripping
about kyrie irving only playing half the
games when james harden only played half
the court there you go ladies and
gentlemen
oh he did his own rim shot there
i like it
anyway that was so corny but that's on
brand for me no if they get all their
guys back plus seth curry like i said i
think i think tim is a better fit he's
still an elite defender an incredible
passer amazing in transition
um
and if he's right
mentally
um i think especially in the half court
and this has been said by a lot if he
could just accept this role by a lot of
people they could accept his role
um and use that passing ability to make
that offense flow
more in line with what kevin durant and
steve nash wanted i think i read where
james harden philosophically wanted a
more iso heavy attack whereas
you know nash and durant want to play
more like the warriors well here's your
draymond green
not that he's as good as draymond no i
know what you're saying no no it's just
interesting you know it's in terms of of
of strategy so what what about the
sixers that you know is hard and not not
have enough time to get in and
maybe next year's a year for it or
i'm just hoping the the the basketball
gods see fit to make this a three six
first round match up four five or
whatever i mean that would just be
dynamite i mean i hope they both play
with it march 10th i hope they can both
play about that i i mean march 10 i i i
don't know do you send simmons into
philadelphia is that what you do i mean
if you want the three six i mean you
gotta get it out of the way at some
point
no that's going to happen i mean the
playoffs he he can't sit out or have
management or whatever you know i think
you rip that band-aid off i mean that's
because
wherever he goes if he goes to brooklyn
i mean i know brooklyn's fan base isn't
what phillies is and they don't he
doesn't have the history in brooklyn but
if he goes to if he struggles in
brooklyn he'll hear booze there too now
he's probably gonna hear booze at every
arena he plays at because even though he
was a philadelphia 76er that became a
national story you'd be hard-pressed to
find an nba fan that did not have an
opinion about ben simmons sixer fan or
not right so
uh but in terms of what was your
question about about the sixers long run
uh or this year are we hard
like so he misses the deadline
conveniently to opt in for next year
like horton is that guy either that that
woman or man whichever that
has a whole lot of relationships like a
serial monogamous he's like yo why you
keep you have no trouble getting a
boyfriend but why have you run through
so many or that person whose resume has
a long list of of employment it's like
why you can't keep a job you can get a
job but you can't keep a job hardened
has run through every superstar in the
nba at this point that he can
realistically do it with so unless and
until it does work with joel embiid i'm
skeptical that it will because for some
reason
it has not worked with harden and
another superstar and b is also not just
a roll to the rim he's not going to take
a back seat uh he's gonna take a
backseat kind of big man he is a you
know if they run the pick and roll game
he's probably more likely to pop than he
has to roll so
it'll be interesting to see how they
gel
in a short period of time and in that
short period of time let's say they
don't win it
let's say they don't win a championship
this year is harden going to have a
wandering eye again does he just want to
be a free agent and pick his team
independent of trade machinations and
ownership input and general manager does
he just want to does he want to be rude
what what's important to him because
what i still believe if had he given it
time
you know and i get the kyrie thing
frustrated him he's not alone in that
but you need to tell me a healthy kevin
durant and healthy james harden could
not have contended in the eastern
conference without kyrie irving i still
believe they could have
well i said yesterday if he doesn't win
with philadelphia or he does it doesn't
work with philadelphia for hardin then
he becomes westbrook
if it does work does he get like the
usual
championship credit oh i think he won
i think he would do the way he got here
oh i think he would i think he would be
uh lionized in philadelphia forever more
if he brings the six as a championship
or he's part of a sixers championship
even if he's just there as a
complimentary piece to in out of
his gourd embiid uh i think he would i
do
look like i mean a ring is a ring don't
get me wrong right and if he's hungry in
his in his marissa told me biological
[ __ ] clock is is doing this it's taking
something yeah then okay i get that and
however he gets it he gets it and
there's no shame in being a number two a
clear-cut number two
two arguably the best big man if not one
of the best players in the nba there's
no shame in that you know whatsoever uh
there's no shame in being no disrespect
to the big o but there's no shame
in being oscar to embiid's kareem if you
will oscar's also one of the greatest
players of all time right but it was
louis fender so regardless
it's a ring will it be line eyes in
philly yeah because their championship
star but james harden the mvp
being so nomadic and such a hired gun
right and the way he forced his way out
of philadelphia the way he's forced his
way out of the the nets
you know i just i question as to whether
or not he'll be viewed in the same vein
as most players
who star players superstar players who
win championships now the other side of
that coin is what he talked about
yesterday maybe this is just somebody
you know a player taking the player
empowerment uh era that we're in to a
whole nother level
and just it hasn't found the right spot
but if you got to go through so much to
find the right spot and so many people
to find the right spot like even if you
count the iterations
of the rockets when he was there both in
terms of supporting cast head coach
and now it didn't work or he didn't want
to see it through
you know with the nets a year later now
he is with the sixers it just i feel
like it's already a referendum on him
and i don't know if that championship
makes me look at him any differently
brilliant individual player brilliant
score brilliant passer
uh you know exceptional talent one of
the best scorers we've ever seen
but
i think he's shown that he's that
proverbial you can't win with him as
your best player thankfully they got
joel and b for that so we'll see how
they fit together we'll see at the top
of the next hour you and michael holly
sir thanks for the call michael smith as
always it's been too long dog don't make
me you know get me worried that you
would trade me for somebody else
yeah i ain't talking rich in a while
you're on my instagram you're on my
instagram i have not scrubbed it i
appreciate it you're welcome take care
y'all be good thanks for hawaii aloha
thank you aloha that's michael smith
everybody brother from another top of
next hour 3 eastern with he and michael
holly right here on nbc sports on
peacock hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here